[Musique]
vinal architectes visage
bref ça je crois que la villa des
architectures vives et aux entraîneurs
quoi il ya beaucoup d'éléments
architecturaux
c'est par définition car le plus
démocrate
merci culture c'est plus qu'un art c'est
d'une manière de vivre ensemble
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo de ce vendredi 3
mais aujourd'hui édition spéciale nous
sommes ici à versailles pour la première
biennale d'architecturé de paysage de la
région ile de france
elle débute aujourd'hui à versailles et
se clôturera le 13 juillet bapt trois
lettres pour découvrir la halle
architecture à travers des lieux de
patrimoine des colloques ou encore des
expositions un moment de réflexion
autour de ce thème l'homme
la ville et la nature
[Musique]
durant 61 jours le public pourra
découvrir si exposition au château de
versailles mais aussi au potager du roi
ou encore dans les écoles nationale
d'architecturé et de paysage
[Musique]
la région ile de france mène depuis le
début de la mandature une politique
d'aménagement et d'urbanisme avec moi sa
présidente valérie pécresse bonjour
bonjour françois de mazières porte
depuis plusieurs années ce combat
pourquoi avoir décidé de vous engager
dans ce projet de la biennale alors
c'est pas françois de mazières qui
portait le projet c'est la région
ile-de-france est un engagement de 2015
que j'ai pris il me paraissait
totalement impensable que l'île de
france n'est pas sa grande biennale
d'architecturé du paysage parce que nous
devons être le lieu nous sommes la
première région d'europe nous devons
être le lieu où l'on crée la réflexion
sur les villes de demain les villes du
futur
et puis vous savez j'avais été très
inspirée par le grand discours de
nicolas sarkozy il ya dix ans sur le
grand paris et je voulais qu'on donne à
voir à tous les franciliens ce que le
grand paris allait être en 2030
alors nous avons lancé cette biennale il
était tout à fait naturel que je confie
ce projet à françois de mazières parce
que françois de mazières était à
l'origine du projet du grand paris à 10
ans en tant que président de la cité de
l'architecturé il m'a proposé
l'écrin de la ville de versailles pour
pour installer cette biennale dans
l'école architecture dans l'école du
paysage au potager du roi et donc c'est
un lieu magique parce que il ya à la
fois l'histoire
les sculptures du louvre les sculpteurs
du château de versailles que personne
n'a jamais vu qu'ils sont pas montrées
au public
et puis il ya aussi ces oeuvres ultra
contemporaine de tous les très grands
architectes français alors justement à
l'occasion de cette biennale
d'architecturé de paysage de la région
ile de france le public pourra découvrir
notamment les projets et les ambitions
du grand paris express lors d'une
exposition au sein de l'ancienne poste
concrètement en quoi cela
permettra-t-elle aux visiteurs de mieux
imaginer tout cela eh bien je crois
qu'on a on a procédé avec des maquettes
et je crois que c'est extrêmement
parlant extrêmement visuel on aime tous
les maquettes depuis qu'on est petit on
aime construire la ville est aujourd'hui
on voit la ville se construire et on ça
va nous donner à toucher tout ce sur
quoi nous sommes en train d'investir
pourquoi tous ces chantiers pourquoi
tous ces travaux en ile de france
aujourd'hui est bien pour sortir demain
des gestes architecturaux manif
pour reconstruire la ville sur la ville
pour réinventer ici les tours ici des
jardins et si des fermes urbaines
réinventer une région avec l'homme la
ville et la nature ensemble le thème de
cette biennale autre projet également le
plan vers la région ile de france
souhaite permettre à tous les
franciliens d'accéder à un espace vert
de proximité à moins de 15 minutes à
pied de chez eux d'ici 2021
en quoi le grand paris express prend
t-il en compte cette dimension
environnementale
alors c'est pas le grand paris express
qui le prend mais c'est la région avec
les maires nous avons lancé un grand
plan de désert mais habile isation des
sols vous savez qu'on a beaucoup bétonné
dans le siècle dernier l'île de france
et nous on veut balader bétonnée on veut
la revégétaliser et on a des projets de
production nette des espaces verts d'ici
2024 avec déjà 100 ha replanter depuis
2016 nous ouvrons 300 hectares de parc
en seine-saint-denis un parc était
complètement fermée au public qui
s'appelle le bois saint martin et nous
plantons le premier arbre de la forêt de
pierres les une forêt d'un million
d'arbres que nous allons planter dans le
val d'oise à l'ouest et de roissy autre
point vous l'avait dit lors de la
conférence de presse construire plus
mais construire beau c'est ça le message
de la biennale d'architecturé de paysage
oui construire plus construire mieux
c'est à dire ne pas s'étendre sur les
espaces naturels et agricoles mais
reconstruire la ville sur la ville donc
construire plus construire mieux et
construire beau parce que tous les
franciliens y ont droit ont droit au bo
la beauté ça n'est pas que paris la
beauté elle doit se retrouver en
banlieue la culture aussi c'est ce qu'a
très bien dit le ministre franck riester
il
des yvelinois au coeur de la campagne
grecque avec leurs partenaires européens
la maison de l'europe des yvelines a
découvert l'île de rhodes entre la mer
egée et la mer méditerranée et notamment
le savoir-faire des habitantes de la
ville d'apollonia on a pu voir l'habitat
traditionnel également les différents
outils utilisés pour tisser mais aussi
tailler le bois presser les olives
récoltées ou obtenir en tout cas du miel
l'île de rhodes le poumon de l'archipel
dodécanèse composée de 160
il est près de 250000 habitants ses
paysages méditerranéens attire près de
2,5 millions de touristes par an à côté
des zones touristiques qui concentrent
beaucoup de touristes on a une culture
agricole très présentes nous avons des
îles isolées des îles - qui ont leurs
propres besoins parce que même une itt
de moins de 50 personnes a besoin d'un
accès à la santé à l'éducation
cela est un challenge pour beaucoup
d'idées face à l' isolement l'île de
tilos développe des panneaux
photovoltaïques et des éoliennes
objectif rendre les habitants autonome
en énergie
on couvre 100% des besoins énergétiques
divers de l'idh est il aussi on ressent
% des besoins énergétiques de lille pour
l'hiver et ont fait un excellent de 30%
pour l'été redistribuer vers les autres
il tout cela pour réduire les
consommations de pétrole
ce séjour s'inscrit dans le projet riz
dit une collaboration entre plusieurs
associations de pays européens avec
comme but de partager les expériences
pour développer les zones rurales
prochaine étape au mois de juin en
pologne
[Musique]
du thermomix des années 70 robot de
cuisine de 2015
l'histoire de nos objets au musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines il
règne comme une atmosphère de madeleine
de proust
un des amis les objets emblématiques
sens veut que tout le monde connaît
c'est la petite
balance terraillon on a ce petit ce
petit appareil qui en fait assez
innovant en matière de maintenance de
cuisine puisque l'ensemble du mécanisme
est cachée pour être enfermé dans une
boîte très design est très
très organique comme ça très très simple
avec les angles arrondis pour sa
nouvelle exposition le musée nous
entraîne dans l'histoire des objets de
notre temps une exposition penser de
manière thématique autour des temps qui
rythment en foyer 7,4 à thématiques sont
l'espace de la cuisine l'hygiène les
nouvelles technologies et le confort et
à travers c'est
donc ces quatre entrées on propose une
série d'objets assez assez divers et qui
qui rendent compte en fait de la manière
dont l'espace domestique donc
l'habitation s'est progressivement dotés
d'un daim
collection d'objets et donc des objets
avec une valeur d usage des usages mais
aussi du design la collection vous même
des années 30 aux années 2010 avec une
période plus présente que les autres les
années 70 on voit arriver une explosion
de couleurs et de formes
évoquons à présent un autre monument des
yvelines après trois ans de fermeture
pour cause de rénovation le musée du
jouet de poissy rouvrira ses portes le
11 mai prochain
installé dans une abbaye du 14e siècle
il renferme 600 jouets et de l'époque
antique à ceux des révolutions
industrielles
un véritable voyage dans le temps que
nous fait découvrir aurélie rose
il était une fois un lieu à poissy où le
monde de l'enfance est à l'honneur trois
niveaux sont entièrement consacrées aux
jeux et aux jouets à travers les
différentes époques
il y à 43 ans ce musée du jouet est le
premier du genre à être créés en france
l'idée est venue d'un du conservateur du
musée pédagogique qui était de l'huma
paris qui était en fait l'héritier du du
musée de jules ferry et du musée de
l'école et c'est cette conservatrice qui
dans les années 70 dans ce musée
pédagogique avait toute une collection
de jouets et elle a cherché un lieu qui
pouvait accueillir cette collection de
jouets pour qu'il soit mieux valoriser
donc nous sommes à peu les héritiers du
musée de gilles férid des années 1880
depuis son ouverture en 1976 c'est la
deuxième fois que le musée fermé au
public pour des travaux de rénovation
il faut dire que le bâtiment qui abrite
ses collections de jouets est inscrit au
titre des monuments historiques
nous ne trouvons ici dans la porterie du
prieuré royal saint louis de poissy qui
a été construit au tout début du 14e
siècle par philip lowe lebel en
l'honneur de son grand-père saint louis
qui est né et a été baptisé ici à poissy
[Musique]
restauration des façades mise aux normes
accessibilité ou encore création d'une
extension
le chantier a duré trois ans objectif
que le public soit accueilli dans de
meilleures conditions et ainsi mieux
voyager dans ses souvenirs d'enfance les
collections présentées ont été en grande
partie renouvelé il ya eu un grand
chantier de restauration des collections
de dépoussiérage et là on présente à peu
près 600 objets sur 14000 qui sont
conservés dans les collections et sont
en grande partie le fruit de dons de
dons de particuliers de collection c'est
que nous ont été légués et sinon c'est
des achats les achats faits en salle des
ventes des achats faits auprès de
particuliers auprès d'antiquaires le
parcours muséographique a été repensée
avec une approche chronologique du jouet
une visite également plus ludique à
travers cette vitrine on peut par
exemple découvrir cette poupée parlante
du second empire
plus insolite encore cette collection de
jouets remontant à l'antiquité prêtés
par le musée du louvre
nous avons déjà là des poupées nous
avons une toupie des osselets le tout
étant introduit par un panneau de
sarcophage sans doute d'une sépulture
d'enfants donc c'est un dépôt d'objets
magnifiques et d'une grande ancienneté
un voyage dans le temps possible dès le
11 mai pour ainsi retrouver son âme
d'enfant
[Musique]
notre édition spéciale à versailles
s'achève je vous le rappelle la bap la
biennale d'architecturé de paysage de la
région ile-de-france se clôturera le 13
juillet de nombreuses expositions vous
sont proposés tout le programme est à
retrouver sur le site qui s'affiche en
bas de votre écran et d'ici là passez un
excellent week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]